it's a tough one this is of course the
the calm before the storm perhaps we
have so little to go on
man's been a vice president politician
the responsible people say give him a
break let's wait and see right he does
my own position and then they say well
he is such a chameleon but he could go
either way so to speak and they point
out that he was historically more
moderate than Reagan who has always had
a wild hair up his nose but I personally
am more of the school that I believe we
do know a lot about this man in fact we
know some things about him that are much
more significant and frightening than
what we knew about Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan was of course a committed
conservative who was known to have a
slightly defective mind through that
severity of that was the case and proved
it and lived up to and had some harsh
policies when he was governor of
California but Bush the CI directorship
where he made these contacts I worked
for him you know I witnessed personally
his supervising the CI is covering up of
illegal activity at the end of the
Angola operation and early 1976 and he
was actually fending off the hostile
Congress instead of investigating and
firing the perpetrators of crimes he was
fending off the FBI in the Congress on
at least three or four major CI criminal
activities what were those activities
well one was the Angolan operation where
we had broken a number of laws much like
the Iran Contra and the Boland kind of
laws and then we had conspired cover up
the breaking of the laws and I mean
literally we sat around the big oak
tables and discussed the law we went
down to the library and read up on the
law wait and then things like I remember
one session reminding the boss you know
don't contradict your separate last week
you said you know don't contradict
yourself this week if Senator so-and-so
brings up a certain issue and this this
one he just plowed right into that one
and he was just telling the Senate you
know the Congress say I don't know I
wasn't here but
I'm sure that I just find it very
difficult to believe but we'll look into
it thoroughly if you'll just give me
some slack and he was reassuring them
and with you know him pat him on the
head they backed off and just never got
back to it he was also doing the same
thing about the assassination of Patrice
Lumumba which was being investigated in
that cycle and also the Chilean
operation the killing of you know the
track 1 track 2 Alistair and killing of
Salvador Allende in Chile and he was
fending off an investigation of that on
in the FBI stuff the Justice Department
was investigating some of the
mercenaries who had been involved in the
CIA's Angola program and they were
asking us specifically which ones had
worked for us and in what capacities and
a young attorney showed up from the
General Counsel's office responding to
Bush's supervision policies and actually
went through my files and purged
documents that he thought would be
legally incriminating if we were
subpoenaed you know if we were
investigated and all of that was a
thorough indication of Bush's policies
as I witnessed them beyond that we have
an incredible record that we will get
into in greater depth as we chat here
now of the connections that he picked up
when he was CI director so we have not
only Noriega but we have a dozen are
dozens of Noriega x' who have blackmail
control of this man now one would like
to give anyone the benefit of a doubt
and say hopefully they're going to be
more moderate but this man even wished
he to be more moderate on CI activities
would have an uphill fight because that
establishment has got so much dirt on
him and I personally don't believe he
really has any desire or instincts to
withdraw from them I think he's I think
he sees a secret world that that goes
back to that
skullenbones thing at Yale that kind of
secret elite manipulation the Knights of
Malta I think he's I think
psychologically he's just deeply
committed to a view of the world where
there's elite insiders who are well
above the normal laws of men and God you
look at see who's been the heads of the
CIA all these years and it's been people
who've been right up at the at the top
and intermingled interlocked with the
top people in the American power
structure it seems that that's such an
important part running an intelligence
service that the establishment to people
don't want any Outsiders doing it what
is the implication then of having an ex
CIA director the President of the United
States this is the first time this has
ever happened that someone who is so
deeply involved in intelligence
activities is actually the president
well it's a giant step towards the
national security state is what it is
it's it's a huge victory for the
national security establishment and
always remember that although it goes
far beyond the CIA but the CIA was
created in the National Security Act of
1947 and the national security
establishment has the CIA as this or one
of the inner chapters so to speak and
have one of its directors bought into
the thing totally and controlled by all
of the illegal activities that he's been
privy to and part of it it means just
that we've been watching and worrying
and people have been writing books for
15 years about the national security
state and this is a giant step in that
direction it's what it amounts that does
that mean that the CIA will have much
more influence in current policy than
they would have
otherwise and the bush has this
mentality the sort of conspiratorial
covert action interventionist view of
the world that these people have how do
you think that might translate
practically into a increased role for
the CIA or creased influence you get
into some nuances or personalities if
you will over all the establishment that
the CIA represents is much stronger
having Bush as as president however it's
difficult to imagine the CI being more
dominant and active than it was under
William Casey for the simple reason that
the man was wild as in a Wild Bill Casey
and he was running poorly thought out
very aggressive operations in every
corner of the world now Bush has decided
to go with William Webster a Webster is
no sighs the head of this is the head of
the CIA which means right yes which
means the head of the intelligence
community because the CI Director
coordinates all of the intelligence in
the seven bureaucracies Webster is no
sane it's not that you know that it
makes you feel reassured in fact he ran
COINTELPRO - in the FBI under Reagan
when they were harassing the people who
were supporting the that are lobbying
against the Contras and he but what's
the most ominous thing about this man is
that the establishment exonerated him
totally he was permitted by the Congress
by the establishment by the the
Washington Post media at the end of that
thing when it was exposed of taking the
idiots out the stupidity out the [ __ ]
out of saying well it's true I was
director of the FBI but I wasn't aware
of any of these activities and you know
the Admiral ship sinks and he said well
I wouldn't wear it had a hole in the
side sounds like the Ronald Reagan
deficient management style were simply
lying on Bush Bush used the same out he
sat in 17 meetings of National Security
Council in which they discussed the
iran-contra scandal
and he says he doesn't remember there
ever having talked about it
it was also another interesting thing
that he said when they asked him about
Oliver North's on one of the TV things
he said well they made two or three
mistakes the fact that it was all
illegal never even known faze him it is
making it back to Webster though it's
it's interesting to note that two levels
of the the intelligence or national
security establishment not the community
are the hard you know the professional
paid professionals the on-duty
professionals but the community has
spoken out at two levels one at the
Henry Kissinger level they've gotten
together and published a paper in which
they have spelled out policies that that
Bush should follow which which speak
pretty openly of brutality towards a
third world and then at a level below
that the Georgetown professors where
McFarland went to work after he left the
White House were ray Klein and others
operate from where they publish these
books the intelligence requirements for
the 80s and now they've come out for the
90s these be Robert Gates the former
deputy director these people have come
out with publications and statements and
and radio interviews and whatnot
vigorously protesting Webster as CIA
director because they say he is soft on
covert action he's not aggressive enough
yet we know that Bush is such a believer
in covert action that at least it's
unlikely there'll be that much of a
curtailing of covert action well it
again in we're getting into new wants it
they're going to run operations for sure
it's a question of how many and how wild
and then at a certain point you see it's
almost in the world's interest God God
knows this is a perverse kind of logic
but it's almost in the world's interest
to have a William Casey as opposed to
William Webster because Casey would go
so far that he would self-destruct right
he was truly a
crazy wild and so these things would be
exposed and there would be a reaction
the Congress would clash with you
endlessly he would mining the harbor's
and lie about it
whereas Webster is muting it with the
Congress and building good relations and
by having a little bit better judgment
he may actually accomplish more in the
long run and it may be harder for us to
crack it open